yes we were taken advantage of we don't
like talking about it um that's Jill
Duggar Dillard speaking out against her
parents in Shiny Happy People Duggar
family secrets the bombshell new Prime
video docu-series alleging Jim Bob and
Michelle abused their 19 Kids and
Counting our Deidre Behar spoke to niece
Amy Duggar King today about her claims
they called it encouragement they
literally said you need to come into the
room and we need to give you some
encouragement is retaliation at all a
fear of yours I'm not afraid anymore
I am gonna speak up for those that can't
speak the four-part series out today
features both cousins and Jim Bob's
sister leveling multiple allegations
against him and wife Michelle while part
of The Devout Christian sect The
Institute in basic life principles the
iblp is a cult people just saw it as
like just a way of living and to be more
you know a little more conservative but
they never saw the abuse that took place
oh hey Mama sit really still look at me
with big old smile I wanna see that
smile now Michelle and Bob deny the
allegations and in a statement called
the doc sad derogatory and
sensationalized they blame quote the
media and those with ill intentions for
hurting people we love the best chance
to repair damaged relationships is
through love in a private setting your
aunt and uncle released a statement yes
I have seen that it was very gaslighting
and it doesn't show any support for the
actual victim items I just hope and pray
that this never happens to anyone else
ever again another controversial subject
that's covered in alleged cover-up for
Josh who sexually abused four of his
sisters that's really really sad that
they're still protecting a pedophile he
just deserves to be on an island just
far far far away from any beautiful
child that he could hurt